car tires crutches flower containers and
carrots
cartels have found creative ways to
smuggle fentanyl across our borders and
into our communities at an alarming rate
and busts of the deadly drug are just
going up
so what are the key cartel strategies
for getting fentanyl into the U.S former
senior DEA special agent and Global
director of Counter Narcotics at regaku
analytological devices Michael Brown
joins us now to explain Michael thanks
for being here thanks for your service
how are Smugglers getting through our
border with this deadly substance
well good morning Pete I mean one of the
primary methodologies used by the
Smugglers now is simply putting you know
millions of tablets of fentanyl or
fentanyl powder into concealed
compartments what we call traps into
vehicles and we know probably 85 to 90
percent of the fentanyl that comes into
the country is coming across the
official borders and vehicles hidden in
cargo or large tractor trailers which
makes it very very difficult to find in
reference to the number of vehicles that
come across the border every day yeah
Michael so if most of it is going
through entry points how many vehicles
are searched because I I know that they
can't search all of them how do they
make that choice
well and this is the the critical point
that the cartels rely on they know that
approximately 80 percent of Border
Personnel now is being drawn from the
border checkpoints to do other issues to
support the the immigration process so
they're using a process what we call
shotgunning they're simply sending
hundreds of vehicles at one time into
the Border ex border checkpoints because
they know Customs can only search a few
vehicles at a time in order to keep that
traffic moving right a lot of vehicles
that are carrying fentanyl will not be
searched so once a vehicle is located it
has fentanyl in it or Methamphetamine or
another narcotic a search team goes and
then they manage that particular vehicle
which takes Personnel away from checking
other vehicles but the cartels
understand this they work this equation
into their distribution calculations
they know a certain amount of fentanyl
will be seized at the checkpoints but
it's a guarantee that they're going to
get four or five or hundreds of other
vehicles through the checkpoints without
being inspected so part of the reason
the foot traffic and and the running
across the border is so problematic is
it draws so much Manpower there that you
have less at official Crossings and then
they can't check every car the cartel
knows that they factor in losses they
send and then they conceal it I mean
it's it's got to take a lot of time in
some instances to find this fentanyl
considering how creative they've gotten
yeah I mean you have to understand that
the cartels have a sophisticated
infrastructure garages which basically
can take a car apart create hidden
cavities and then reseal you know
millions of pills into the the framework
of a vehicle or a tractor trailer and to
find that you would have to you'd have
to x-ray the vehicle then you'd have to
have a crew out there to actually break
the vehicle down to find these bulk
substances and of course once they cross
the border they go to a garage and the
vehicle is then taken apart the drugs
are taken out and the vehicle sent back
to Mexico for another shipment so not
only is it time consuming but it's
incredibly difficult to find Find the
tails or the signs of these vehicles
that are actually carrying fentanyl man
Michael when you break that down it get
it gives you a sense of the scope of the
problem we face which doesn't seem to be
getting any better and and you speak
with a lot of expertise Michael Brown
thank you so much for your time thank
you Pete take care you got it I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis